c'est donc une rupture de confiance pour
paris qui ne décolère pas après la
sphère des sous-marins une crise qui
affecte toute l'union européenne selon
le chef de la diplomatie européenne
la crise diplomatique sans précédent
s'invite même à l'assemblée générale de
l'onu à new york on y retrouve notre
correspondant thomas bonnet bonsoir
thomas joe biden qui s'est donc exprimé
pour la première fois à la tribune le
président américain qui sont bouilloire
jouer l'apaisement et promet un retour à
la diplomatie
absolument les s'agissait de la première
déclaration le premier discours de joe
biden à l'onu en tant que président des
états unis et il a passé en revue les
différentes positions américaine sur un
certain nombre de dossiers il a
notamment insisté sur deux axes la lutte
contre la pandémie de kobe de 19 essais
qu'on la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique il est également revenu
évidemment sur la fin de la guerre menée
par les etats-unis en afghanistan alors
joe biden pendant tout le long de son
discours à prôner l'unité le
multilatéralisme alors que c'est
justement l'un vers ce qui lui est
reproché actuellement par la france et
plus généralement par l'union européenne
un appel à l'unité qui peut sonner assez
bizarrement aujourd'hui surtout que la
diplomatie américaine par ses
déclarations par ses prises de position
à participer à augmenter les tensions
avec la chine écoutez donc cet extrait
du discours de john f
nous ne cherchons pas une nouvelle
guerre froide
nous ne cherchons pas un monde divisé en
bloc rigide les etats unis sont prêts à
travailler avec toute nation et qui
recherchera un règlement pacifique
des différends même si nous avons un
désaccord profond dans d'autres domaines
parce que nous espérons tous les
conséquences de notre échec si nous ne
nous unissons pas pour faire face à la
menace urgente de lakovic 19 des
changements climatiques au des menaces
prolonger telles que la prolifération
nucléaire les grands absents de cette
réunion thomas emmanuel macron
représenté par son chef de la diplomatie
un signe que la situation est grave
entre paris et washington
oui parce que initialement l'elysée
avait indiqué que emmanuel macron
prévoyait d'enregistrer un message vidéo
qui aurait été projetée pendant cette
assemblée générale des nations unies
mais finalement donc le président de la
république française il ya renoncé c'est
sans doute un message symbolique pour
marquer la colère de la france à l'égard
des états unis et donc à la place c'est
jean yves le drian qui est à new york
cette semaine il a déjà tenu une
conférence de presse ce lundi où il a
une nouvelle fois était très véhément
contre washington il a encore une fois
effectué une comparaison entre joe biden
et son prédécesseur donald trump écouter
ses déclarations de jean yves le drian
lui ni latéral isme
l'imprévisibilité
le défaut de concertation entre alliés
que nous avons constatées dans la
décision prise par l'australie et les
états unis
c'est la permanence de réflexes d'une
époque que nous espérions révolue
notez qu'il n'y a pas de rencontre
prévue entre jean yves le drian et son
homologue américain anthony blinken le
chef de la diplomatie française a
simplement indiqué que les deux hommes
auront sans doute l'occasion de se
croiser dans les couloirs du siège des
nations unies en revanche un appel
téléphonique devrait avoir lieu dans les
prochains jours entre emmanuel macron
ninja gaiden l'occasion pour les deux
hommes de s'expliquer est aussi
l'occasion de mesurer à quel point cette
crise est profonde surtout qui a eu de
nouvelles révélations de la part du new
york times le quotidien américain
affirme qu'au mois de juin dernier à
cornwall lors de ce sommet qui était
organisé en europe vous savez ccl ce
sommet où joe biden mails macron s'était
montré particulièrement proches et bien
à ce moment-là elle joe biden n'aurait
pas dit un seul mot à au président
français sur ce contrat qui était
pourtant en pleines tractations
parce que au même moment joe biden
rencontrait le premier ministre
britannique et le premier ministre
australien justement pour parler de ce
contrat de sous-marins voilà qui ne va
pas aider à améliorer les relations
entre paris et washington alors en
attendant de parler avec mails macron
dans les prochains jours joe biden avait
deux rencontres prévues à son agenda
aujourd'hui une avec le premier ministre
australien justement ça s'est passé au
siège des nations unies et puis l'autre
aura lieu ce soir à la maison-blanche
joe biden recevra le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson évidemment
difficile d'y voir une coïncidence en
lien avec l'actualité merci thomas
bonnet en direct de new york